the dua, the supplication of
Allah says, we answered his dua
for him. And we relieved what
hardship was upon him.
Immediately. And we replaced
him and we gave him his family
back. And those them along
with them. Ayub Alaihi Salam,
his children were killed in a
freak accident as we've
mentioned before. scholars
differ on the meaning of this
verse. We were placed for him,
his family, meaning his
children. Does this mean that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
resurrected his children for
him? Or does this mean that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
replace them with other
children from his wife in a
natural way? two opinions of
the scholars. Both are
plausible, both are correct
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
as a mercy from us. And a
remembrance for those who are,
those who worship Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
a remembrance for those who
worship almost as if to say
this is not something specific
to Ayub Alaihi Salam. Rather
this is something that
is for a yule and those who are
most similar to ayub. A person
is in hardship. Their worship
of Allah is what? What helps to
relieve this hardship that they
are in and if they make dua to
Allah they are answered by
Allah. However, the answer to
their Dua may not come in the
form that they imagine. And
this is one of the big problems
that people have in
understanding the dynamics of
Dua. How many of us can
honestly say that we know
exactly what we want? How many
of how many of us can honestly
say with conviction that we
know exactly what we need?
I can't say exactly what I need
and I can't even say exactly
what I want because it changes.
I disagree today with myself
last year. I disagree with
myself today than I did. Last
week. I certainly disagree with
my ambitions. 10 years ago. and
so, the human being makes dua.
Asks for things from Allah.
However, it is of the human
being's best interest that he
is not given exactly what he
asks for. Rather, he is given
the spirit of what he asks for.
What does that mean? Allah if
he were to give us everything
that we asked for, we would
self destruct Because we would
be asking for things that would
be terrible for us. However,
when we make dua, As the
prophet said, Allah does not
look to your outward images
rather he looks to your hearts
and your actions. When we make
dua, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
looks to the spirits of that
which we are asking for. and he
answers our Dua if it is
accepted by Allah with that
which is best for us not
necessarily that which is that
which we necessarily ask for
specifically. There's a
narration in which the prophet
said that Allah will answer the
dua of a person who makes dua.
Who supplicates. as long as
this person does not ask for
that which is sinful in their
dua. Or is sinful in his dua.
And as long as a person is not
hasty in their supplication.
What does that mean hasty?
Prophet was asked the same
exact question. What does it
mean to be hasty in making dua?
Do not exhibit patience in
making dua. The prophet said
that is that a person says I
made dua and it was an
answered. Person should never
have this attitude. This will
stop dua. will. This will
deplete Dua. And Dua may not
come exactly when a person
wants. Because maybe it's not
the correct time for it.
Likewise, Dua is answered in a
number of ways. It may not be
answered in the way that you or
I may envision or most desire
at the moment. Rather, dua may
be answered in a number of
ways.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala may
give the person exactly what
they ask for. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala may repel the harm.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala may
keep this dua for the day of
resurrection that the person
benefit from it on that day. Or
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
at least reward a person for
their dua. Because dua is of
the greatest forms of worship.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
and remember Ismael and Idris
and Al Kefir. Ismael, the
brother of Ishab, the brother
of Isaiah, one of the two sons
of Ibrahim Alaihi Salam. And he
is the forefather of the
prophet Muhammad Idris, it's a
difference of opinion
a prophet after nor before What
seems to be the best opinion is
that Idris
aim after Noah. That Idris is
actually one of the prophets of
because Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentioned him along with
the prophets of Benius Rael.
Surat Mariam and elsewhere.
another opinion is that Idris
was the first prophet and Noah
was the first messenger. This
is a weaker opinion though it
is more popular amongst Islamic
historians. And as far as the
stories that we find in some of
the books of the stories of the
prophets that Idris came before
Noor and he was the first one
to ever wage war and jihad and
all this stuff. A lot of these
narrations, if not, most of
them are either fabrications
or taken from the people of the
book.
Is in the correct opinion, a
prophet as well. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says, each
of them was of the patient
ones. So, patience is the thing
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
most prays these prophets for.
And he didn't limited to only
these three prophets. He said
they are of the patient. All of
the prophets were patient.
Though their patience were of
varying degrees. Which we will
see inshallah in the next
verses.
[Arabic recitation]